bonsoir verra un entretien de près de
deux heures avec le président français
depuis plus d'une heure avec le
président américain cette fois ci quelle
a été la teneur de ces échanges verra
bonsoir sophie effectivement beaucoup de
tractations diplomatiques ce samedi
temps sur leur comble dans le dossier
ukrainien après l'annoncé par plusieurs
médias américains de la date exacte de
l'invasion supposé russe de l'ukraine
selon politico qui se réfère aux sources
de la maison blanche la russie prévoit
une attaque le 16 février quand l agence
bloomberg elle évoque le 15 février plus
tôt ce conseiller américain à la
sécurité nationale james et les vannes
qui a estimé que l'invasion était prévu
avant la fin des g aux jeux olympiques
au à pékin c'est à dire avant le 20
février lors de leur conversation
téléphonique joe biden a prévenu
vladimir poutine que la russie allait
faire face à des conséquences graves de
la part des états unis et de leurs
alliés en cas d'escaladé l'ukraine et
concernant la partie russe le kremlin
dénoncé une hystérie américaine à
l'apogée après l'appel des présidents
mais quand même les deux présidents se
sont mis d'accord pour poursuivre le
dialogue le président oui s'est
également entretenu avec son homologue
français l'entrevue téléphonique a duré
1h40
selon le kremlin les deux présidents
discuter de la situation les
spéculations provocatrice quant à une
prétendue invasion russe de l'ukraine
qui s'accompagne de livraison d'ampleur
d'armements modernes à ce pays je vous
propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine a de nouveau attiré
l'attention sur l'absence de réponse
substantielle de la part des états unis
et de l'otan aux initiatives russes bien
connu il a souligné la réticence des
principaux pays occidentaux a poussé les
autorités de kiev à mettre en oeuvre les
accords de minsk ce qui s'est une
nouvelle fois manifesté lors de la série
de consultations des conseillers
politiques des dirigeants des états due
forme en normandie qui s'est tenu sans
résultat le 10 février à berlin compte
rendu
lisez le président français a fait
savoir à son homologue russe qu'un
dialogue sincère et n'étaient pas
compatibles avec une escalade militaire
à la frontière russo ukrainienne
toujours d'après la présidence française
emmanuelle mâcon et vladimir poutine ont
toutes deux exprimé une volonté de
poursuivre le dialogue sur les voies
pour avancer sur la mise en oeuvre des
accords de misc sur le dôme basse et sur
les accords de la sécurité et la
stabilité en europe
merci beaucoup verhaeghe hoffman en
direct de moscou